this is a typical new york city avenue
the new york city sidewalk cafe
initiative
has allowed us to take over a lane of
traffic on either side
and put in sidewalk cafes
hi i'm sterling plenart i'm a restaurant
and retail architect
i've worked on the design of all of
these restaurants
today i'm going to talk about restaurant
design here in new york city
with covid restrictions
[Music]
before we get into the details of how
restaurants have responded to the covid
virus we need to get into the design of
restaurants pre-covet new york city
restaurants are long narrow spaces
typically
because they're taking up the base of a
tenement building this is a typical new
york city restaurant floor plan
they tend to be 20 to 25 foot wide
60 to 80 foot long and have many
obstacles that reduce that width even
further
including staircases elevators
service doors hallways which can reduce
the width down
to roughly 15 feet so then
kovid hit the typical restaurant that we
just walked through
suddenly lost all of its occupancy
so pre-covid a restaurant which had 40
persons
able to dine in the restaurant has been
reduced to 10 persons
they are however allowed to expand into
a lane of traffic which allows them to
add
16 persons depending on the size of
their space
pre-covid a restaurant's goal was to
look full to look inviting to look like
a space that a person wants to go and
dine in that's completely upended now
now you need a place that looks safe to
go which is a different environment
you don't want a restaurant that's
packed with people indoors you want a
restaurant that feels like they're
taking your safety seriously which means
the outdoor dining
is separated in july of this year new
york city released guidelines for how
a restaurant can expand onto the streets
this is new york city's guideline
diagram a building which has a frontage
which is the
width of their storefront can then do a
restaurant out on the street
for outdoor dining with some exceptions
so in the beginning there were makeshift
structures so these restaurant
designs are simple quick effective ways
to define a space
simply created using construction
pallets
tent structures to keep the weather out
tables are spaced
six feet apart a raised floor allows for
ada access
safety barrier elements that protect
your patrons from traffic
and the adjacent spaces so the challenge
of this first phase
of outdoor sidewalk dining is that if
you have a car
directly adjacent to somebody sitting at
a table
having dinner it's not a very nice
environment it doesn't feel
like a safe comfortable place to eat
you're mixing
their exhaust smoke with your fine
dining experience
mayor de blasio announced that sidewalk
dining would become a permanent
element of new york city in this next
phase
restaurateurs had figured out a couple
ways to
enhance their space very inexpensively
including
adding landscaping along the perimeter
barricade this serve the purpose
of softening the structures as well as
providing that respite from
new york city traffic exhaust another
one of the
challenges of a new york city restaurant
the new york city street
tends to be arced so that water drains
into the gutters
and it's really not that pleasant to be
at a table that's sitting
on an angle by adding a floor that's
flush with the sidewalk
you end up with a straight flat surface
that is ada accessible
and makes for a better dining experience
so these structures
really only work in good weather nobody
wants to sit
out on the street when it's raining out
sidewalk cafes have been very successful
over the summer here in new york city
but now we're moving into the fall and
winter months when the temperature is
dropping
the question becomes how do you
winterize an outdoor sidewalk cafe
while meeting the rules of covid so in
new york city in winter
you're going to have rain coming from
above you're going to have wind
blowing from the sides water and ice and
snow
building up on the streets so you're
making a contained environment that
shields you from these elements we start
adding elements
like roofs you end up adding walls and
then
clear vinyl sheets so what you have to
be careful not to do
is fully enclose the outdoor environment
basically building a building on the
street you need to keep
at least 50 percent of your area
of walls and ceilings open usually one
facade
facing the restaurant this gives you the
dual purpose
of getting the airflow but also the
people in the restaurant
servers wait staff can see everybody in
there and take care of them
they're not hidden behind a wall if you
fully enclose
your outdoor dining space it's no
different than an indoor restaurant at
that point
so in the case of this greenhouse type
structure
this becomes indoor dining new york city
said you can do that on the street as
well but then you have to follow the
rules of indoor dining tables need to be
a certain distance apart you only have
25
occupancy so the goal of this next phase
of
sidewalk cafes it's to make a
pleasant experience of outdoor dining
similar to what you had pre-cove
indoor dining it's to make it year-round
dining
a space that people are comfortable
going in mid-summer or mid-winter
equally well and it's basically to
allow restaurateurs to have enough
tables to keep in business
to get through the end of this crisis
the outdoor dining
initiative in new york city has been
phenomenally successful prior to covid
there were 24
000 restaurants approximately in new
york city
since new york city instituted the
outdoor dining over 10
000 of them have opened up outdoor
dining spaces
now i'm going to walk you through
restaurant design pre and post covid
you start out on the street storefront
signage that's your first experience of
the restaurant
as you walk in how you're greeted is
your second part of the experience
then you actually get to sit at your
table and your experience is taken over
by the food the
atmosphere and the service in the
restaurant
so post covid the experience of walking
up to a restaurant
is very different you need to socially
distance you've got your six foot
space decals on the street the dots that
have been put on sidewalks
and everything else around the city are
fairly effective when you come in you no
longer see
diners right away what you see is a host
stand
with takeout instructions so you're
picking up orders
having food to go part of the signage
package that's involved in a restaurant
now
are things like face covering
requirements how you go to the bathroom
in a restaurant
what the rules are when you're in the
restaurant so these photos are of
restaurants obviously pre-covered which
show the activity the interaction of
people the primary directive
is to get the people at the tables that
are able to be seen from the exterior
food and beverages both look better
under natural light
post covid you're going to have far
fewer people you're going to lose
every other table here many restaurants
have introduced
signage on the tables which includes
things like qr codes for the menus one
of the main advantages to restaurants
that this has brought out is they can
now change their menu on a daily basis
without having to reprint reformat their
menus
everything's on the phone so that's how
the restaurant experience has changed
post covid
now i'm going to talk about the future
of dining in new york city
so as we move into the next phase of
sidewalk cafes
new york can learn a lot from european
cities while outdoor dining in new york
city
and taking back streets from vehicular
traffic is something new for us
in europe it's been happening for years
european cities have plazas
sidewalks all filled with outdoor dining
and seating situations it's part of the
urban
fabric of those cities and it's very
successful it makes the streets safer
it makes them more active and it extends
the life of those sidewalks and
cafes further into the evening or
earlier in the morning because
it's part of the cityscape so some of
the things we can learn from european
cities
and how they interact with their outdoor
dining is that it doesn't have to be
an interference in the sidewalk or
streetscape
in some cases they've extended the
storefront
out onto the street or sidewalk they've
allowed it to be
part of the restaurant just an outdoor
portion of it and similar to what we're
doing here in new york city
they've created platforms that are
separate from the restaurant and the
sidewalk goes between them
some of the more successful restaurants
have faced all of the streets
towards the street it becomes an
interactive viewing almost like
theater some of the streets in europe
that are most famous for doing this
are the champ de lisa in paris or la
ramblas in barcelona
where having sidewalk cafes and dining
has not only become a draw for it it's
become a tourist attraction in its own
right
one of the big design challenges in new
york city is that we don't have service
ways or alleyways behind the buildings
any sidewalk cafes or outdoor dining
that we design
are going to have to compete with those
services for space on the street
covett has accelerated a program in new
york city called open streets
treats closed or mostly closed vehicular
traffic
opening them up for pedestrians and
non-vehicular uses
new york city had 87 separate open
street designations
spread throughout the city so this is
what a new york city open street
might look like you've got sidewalk
dining on either side
you've opened up to pedestrians it
becomes like a block party that's
permanent
what the future might hold is a full
greening of new york city
where it's not just closing down a
couple streets and putting in painted
plazas
you add green scape you add trees you
add
landscaping and new york city becomes a
much greener
and friendlier place to be the overall
effect of this would be turning avenues
in new york city
into linear parks similar to the high
line
going by the numbers new york city
restaurants are definitely in trouble
due to covid they've been closed down
for many months
estimates are approximately 40 percent
of the restaurants in new york city will
not make it through this crisis
architects and designers are assisting
restaurants
as quickly as possible to help them make
these cafes work
make sidewalk cafes winterized and be
able to work year-round and become a
permanent part of the new york city
streetscape
covet has obviously been a horrendous
impediment to
restaurants in new york city however
there is a silver lining
despite the tragedy of the disease it
has
allowed us to help reshape the city
and how residents and tourists visiting
it interact with the environment